You are very critical of postmodernism wave of the 60s isn't there a danger of
throwing the baby out with the bath water?
Are the positive things about these movements at the moment?
No,
not really.
I don't think there's much positive about them at all.
I think they've gone way too far.
I think they dominate the humanities.
The postmodernism mean the fact that the postmodernist point is that there is a
very large number of ways to interpret any closed set of phenomena,
something like that.
Any limited set of phenomena.
And that's true,
but it's,
it's shallow,
it's very,
very shallow doctrine.
And uh,
if,
if I'm throwing the baby out with the bath water,
then it's a baby that needs to be thrown out at afraid.
Are the positive things about these movements?
Not at the moment.
I can't see anything positive about it.
I think it's,
it's degenerated into ideological clap trap and I think it's destroying the
universities.
So the egalitarian waiver of the 60s that's a different issue I would say.
I mean at mean I don't think it's reasonable to deny the utility of the civil
rights movement in the 1960s,
for example.
And,
or,
and,
you know,
there were movements before that,
like the labor movement that had real justification for being,
it isn't that everything that always happens on the left is bad.
I don't think that at all.
I think that the people who are,
let's say on the lower end of the economic distribution,
need a powerful voice in politics.
Um,
I think that's only fair.
And I mean,
there is room for an egalitarian oriented he thoughts,
but that isn't what equity is.
This has become completely ideological and there's just no,
there's just no excuse for it as far as I'm concerned.